now there's only one last thing you need
before you can have a go at this and
practice it and that's to extend this of
the channel but before I do that are
there any questions like there's a lot
of concepts on the board ideas you are
some you're giving me the only
clarification on a theme face
yeahi please ask the question the black
one here okay great I did I did go
through quickly okay what are we trying
to do on this black curve here okay what
I'm trying to say is what is the
gradient of this y equals log X curve
what is the gradient doing okay now what
I notice is I'm just going to go from
left to right if that's okay at the
leftmost part of the graph it's
increasing and it's doing it real fast
it's really steep is the colloquy I
would say right so when you have a line
that has a steep gradient that means the
gradient is very large and positive yeah
large and positive so this is a high
value for the derivative so I just put
an X up that's quite high but as I
progress from left to right do you
notice
well this spot here is not as steep at
this spot over here is that okay it's
not a steep and in fact the more I go to
the right not a state not as steep not
as steep so that means that the
derivative the gradient should be lower
and lower and lower it's still positive
because my original graph is still going
up but it's slowing down okay
so that's why the black graph which
tells me the gradient it's still all of
these values are positive they're above
the x axis but they're getting smaller
and smaller and smaller which indicates
that this guy is slowing down slowing
down forever in fact is that a better
explanation or yeah you still what you
reckon what do you got you
ah that is a very good question how did
I come up with this okay now the short
answer is at the moment off the
information that we've got I kind of
guessed like this is the only graph that
I know about that basically does this
but you're right to ask well why this
one like 2 over X well why not 1 over x
squared that also looks roughly the same
okay now this is 1 comma 0 and this
would be 1 comma 1
so they intersect somewhere else ok now
as to like the actual answer to question
I will show you that and it's actually
really love that you all know enough to
prove that it's 1 over X but the reason
I'm not showing you that is because well
number one the course doesn't require it
and some of you were just like I want to
use the rule and I want to get used to
it
and that's that's fine honestly from the
point of view of the course so I want to
let you have this result and you can use
it even if you're not curious as to why
exactly but I will show all of you why
exactly because you can get it and I
think you'll be really satisfied by okay
does that does that answer your question
sort of yep I know it's not satisfying
I'm not that satisfied to stop you're
either but I am gonna show you what you
need to know and then I'll show you a
bit extra after that okay may I move to
this next bit can I get some noise
yes thumbs up okay fantastic thank you
here's what I gonna do we're gonna take
this log X and we're gonna look at what
if it's not log of just X what it's what
if it's log of some other thing right
could be log of 2 X plus 1 it can be log
of 2 sine X it could be log of anything
can we still differentiate that and the
answer is yes we can I'll show you how
if we have let's consider some new
function y equals log of something else
I'm gonna call log of f of X some other
function and I really don't care what
other function it is I'm gonna do chain
rule to this thing and I'll walk you
through it step by step and we can work
out what the result is okay the first
thing is I need to give this guy a name
I'm gonna call this you actually don't
need to give in it but it's going to be
a little easier for you to see if I do
so therefore I can write y equals log of
U and from this
I can just differentiate that that's the
result but we just did right dy on it's
not DX this time because I don't have
any X's in this question it's gonna be D
u yeah what dy undo you I've got the
results just up above it's one over yeah
I don't have X's I've got yous so I'm
going to say 1 over U is that okay so
this is me just rehearsing this result
just with different pronumerals okay so
that's good
I've got you being equal to f of X so in
the same way I can now take this guy and
differentiate that's how chain rule
works yeah but we've got a chain of
derivatives one after the other so here
I'm going to do do you on DX okay
there's a bit weird cuz I don't know
what f of X is like I said it could be
anything so I'm just going to say like
what do we call the derivative of f of X
it has like a label that we give on it f
dash X F dash X okay so now see these
guys these two drivers I can as the name
of the rules suggest I can chain them
together in sequence I can say dy on D u
times D you on DX that's just these two
things right so I'm just going to write
them down 1 over u F dash X let me hit
pause how you feeling so far is that
okay well you're all right with how a
differentiating this just using this
rule we just established and you account
our differentiated bits like that's just
what the derivative this is corn I don't
know what F is so I can't call it
anything else is that alright and then I
just substituted you okay I'm almost at
the end here chain rule right
I've got these two D used one on the top
one on the bottom so what can I do with
them I can I can cancel them out right
they go so I get left with what on the
left hand side dy on DX that's the
actual derivative I want dy on DX okay
then I have this fraction times f dash X
so this F dash X I'm going to write it
on the
for the fraction is that okay one times
F dash is just f dash and then on the
bottom I could write you that's what
I've got from the previous line but
haven't looked carefully just a couple
lines above I defined you right here see
that that's you okay so I can replace
you with what what I can get rid of all
the use I I put them in to help me solve
it but I don't need them so it's just f
of X so when I got here when you've got
just a log function log of X when you
differentiate it you get the hyperbola
one over X but actually if you've got
the log of anything the log of anything
its derivative is whatever the
derivative of that is which is f dash
divided by whatever that is okay so
let's use some of the examples that we
can see over there I'm just going to
make myself a little tiny bit of space
let's suppose I had what was what was
question 4 okay let's suppose I had the
derivative of log x squared minus 3
that's what I put up in the power yeah
that's what we had before
okay let's do it there's F that's the
thing being taking a log off right so I
want F dash on F what's F dash in this
case it's just 2x yeah because I don't
need to worry about this new 3 so it's
2x there's the F dash on the top what
goes on the bottom just just that f of X
so it's x squared minus 3 and you're
done that's it these derivatives of
Exponential's and logs are super useful
but they're also really easy to work out
they're not hard you just have to use
fairly straightforward rules okay so
here's our undoing and hit pause these
questions here work through all of these
okay so I'm gonna let you have a go and
have a play okay but some of you gonna
have the same question Alicia had which
is yeah but all of this depends on this
and we just kind of looked at a picture
and sort of guessed right well I'm
give you the proof for it and like I
said it relies on stuff that you all
actually know if you're really clever
about it you could work it out yourself
but I will help you out I'll hold your
hand just because I think it's satisfied
to know why things are the case